every business needs to solve each of
these four problems in in order to make
more money and scale and the first of
those problems is figuring out the
customer that you're actually going to
serve and in talking to many of you the
issue is you have no idea and that's
okay because in the beginning you need
to sell everyone because you have no
money and they have a pulse and a credit
card and you only require one of those
things and so you ask them for their
credit card so that you can pay your
bills so you can actually make your
business work and that's okay and that's
normal and that's expected but when you
keep taking every single Tom Dick and
Harry who can give you you know a third
down today and I'll pay you when I get
paid and and everything else they're
like hey do you think you could you know
give me the world and you're like I
could give you two worlds and you're
they're like awesome here's my credit
card again Bill me on the fifth that's
when I get paid right and you deal with
all of these bad customers and you
promise the world which is normal in the
beginning because there's only you and
you maybe can help this person in a
completely unscalable way and that's
what you should do because you just need
to generate income you need to generate
Word of Mouth you need to help people
out cool but there comes a point and
it's usually around a million bucks a
year sometimes three million bucks a
year where the operational complexity of
the business becomes really tough
because now you've got a lot of
different customers that all have
different needs that have different
Promises at different price points that
you've sold and they're still just you
and so this process is the sticking
point this this is sticking point number
one what you have to do is you have to
learn how to say no to people who are
not the ideal customer and if you're
like well I don't know who my deal a
customer is that is the problem and so
you take all of the customers that you
have that you have sold over your entire
history and then you look at them and
you say which of these people do I love
okay column one which of these people
have spent the most money column two
which of these people did I have the
highest operational profit from column
three column
four which of these was the easiest to
deliver on and so you look at these
different list and you're like huh are
there any common themes are there are
there any people who are in two or three
of those columns I really like them they
made me a lot of money and it was really
easy to deliver the thing huh well
that's weird because that's not the main
thing that I sell but I guess I have
sold a few of those huh well if you were
to then take that concept and say well
if 10% % of my customers are in this
really ideal bucket what if I had 100%
of my customers that were just like that
so you take the same amount of customers
you currently have but they were all
just that customer if you do the math
again you usually make five to 10 times
more money and the cool part about that
process is that it doesn't require more
infrastructure you already have the
infrastructure to service that number of
customers you're just servicing the
wrong people because you haven't learned
to say no yet and so one of the most
attractive things in marketing and sales
is saying I don't need your money
because it makes everybody want you more
and so what you do to harness this is
you tell everybody you actually don't
want to sell that you actually don't
want to sell them and crazy I know and
then you let the people who are the
right type of person because they're
like oh I'm not that I'm not that hate
those people too oh and you say but if
you just happen to be this perfect
unicorn that has these two three four
traits I can absolutely change your life
in this very specific way that means a
lot to you and they're like wow sounds
like this ads just for me and that's
exactly what I want and guess what
happens now once you make that kind of
change in messaging you attract more of
that right type of customer you can now
charge the premium price even at the
more operationally efficient and product
High service level because now you're
doing the same thing for every single
customer so you get better at doing it
so you get higher percentage success
rates you do it at higher margins
because you both have higher price and
lower cost for doing this and this is
how you solve problem number one but you
have to learn how to say no and most
people literally never
learn and so I get I have had this
conversation so many times that I want
to shout it into a microphone which is
what I'm doing right now okay so that's
how you solve problem number
one problem number two that I see
businesses get stuck at where they're in
Rocking a hard place they're like I
don't know what to do it's two sides of
the same problem you either charge too
little or you pay too
much and I want to put caveats around
this I'm a big believer in hiring great
talent I'm a big believer in bringing
good people in absolutely but if you
want to have a frozen yogurt store and
you want to pay the people behind the
counter 20% of Revenue each your
business will not make
money if I'm lying I'm
dying if you have a physical therapy
where you
at Physical Therapy Clinic and you give
50% of Revenue to every one of your
people tough to scale that was somebody
here you have to nail the individual
model where you can make enough money at
full capacity and so which is going to
trickle into problem three but you get
into this position where like wait I
realize now that I can't give profit
shares to every single person I
specifically can't give Revenue shares
to all these people or my salesman can't
make more than I do right in the
business and maybe they do in the
beginning but at scale they shouldn't be
able to more than the owners right then
you have something that's that's
mismatched and so you have to have these
moments because otherwise business
owners will stay in this Lane for years
because they'll just say like well if I
if I tell them I have to change their
comp then I'm going to lose them and I'm
like yeah and if you don't you'll never
grow so which one do you want to do and
so that the the the nefarious part about
each of these problems is that they have
a appearing impossible issues with each
one of them with the first one you're
like well I can't say no to money
because I need the money in order to pay
my bills but by saying yes to people who
aren't the ideal customer then I will
never be able to grow this business
because I won't be able to charge the
premium prices get the best customers
have the operational margin that I need
in order to expand and so all of these
are Rock and Hard Place problems but you
have to have the intestinal fortitude
and this is why your lifestyle as your
competitor's opportunity
what you require to live on is what
prevents you from being aggressive in
the business to make the best decision
of the business because the business
doesn't care like the ideal perfect
version of your business exists you just
have a number of steps that you have to
take to get there and the people who get
there faster are the ones who are
willing to stomach uncomfortable
conversations low profit months and a
hit on their lifestyle for extended
periods of time and so you being able to
be aggressive with your lifestyle when I
say aggressive I mean being able to live
on very little espe especially when
you're in that 1 three 5 million a year
range allows you to take bigger risks
think longer because you're like okay
we're going to change this thing well
I've got 100 Grand saved up and so I can
stomach a year if I need to take nothing
out so that we can make this pivot
because this what's right for the
business now and more specifically this
is right for the business for the next
five years and so rocking hard place so
if you're with the I have all these
employees and they're all compensated in
correctly you have to sit down and you
have to say hey guys and this is how I
deal with all really hard conversations
I just tell the truth I messed up I said
that I was going to help you guys grow
with this business I said we were going
to do these big things but based on the
decisions that I made because I'm a
numbnuts I mispriced your compensation
and because of that I'll never be able
to give you career growth I'll never be
able to reinvest in you I'll never be
able to the opportunity to open new
locations or move up in this business
because this business will not grow
based on how this works but if you're
willing to go on this ride with me and
change how compensation works and to be
clear I'm taking nothing so like you
work every month and you still get a
paycheck I work every month and I get
poor that's the difference so I just
want to be clear I'm in this ride with
you and I'm Tak I'm not ask you to do
something I'm not willing to do but if
you're willing to go on this ride with
me for six months maybe 12 months we're
going to have opportunities to be 10
times bigger than this because be right
for the business but you have to have
that talk otherwise you will be stuck in
this well if they leave then I won have
a business and some of them will leave
and guess what skill you get to develop
now the ability to recruit Talent with
your new compensation structure with
your new vision of what's going to
happen in their lives along with your
business so that's the second problem
and the second sticking point and each
of these are just these levels that
people just go around and they just stay
stuck for
years this part 2B of that one is not
charging enough and so this is the this
is how it presents
hey my business is at full capacity my
business is at full capacity and uh
we're not making that much money and so
I think I need to open a new location or
I need to add another product line when
this is the core thing of the business
if the core thing of the business at
capacity even at a small level of
capacity like if you have one rep that
can handle 10 people for your agency or
you have one physical therapist who can
handle 50 patience it doesn't matter
there's going to be some ratio of of
cost of goods sold and what you what you
charge and then you have other costs
associated administrative and fixed cost
whatever and there's going to be a a
point of capacity with that small unit
where if you're still not making money
the business model is flawed and so
either you need to find a way to
dramatically decrease the cost that you
have to deliver which sometimes it's the
compensation of the employee team if
it's way off or oftentimes it's just
you're charging too little and you just
and there's all these ethical things of
like I feel like an impostor and I'm
like dude you're not an impostor you're
broke you only get impostor syndrome
when you pretend to be something you're
not like I get this question all the
time like I feel like an impostor for
charging that much money you only feel
like an imposter because you're
lying if you like I had a an a agency
owner yesterday who said I had an agency
I got to 150 clients and I have a really
good client getting system
um but that that business stalled
because I didn't know how to operate um
and so it kind of like crashed and
burned but I knew how to get customers
for my agency really really well he's
like but I feel like an impostor
charging for that system and I was like
why and I was like is it because you're
pretending you were a really successful
agency owner he was
like yeah I was like well then why don't
you just tell the truth and say I got
150 customers despite not knowing
anything about running an agency because
the system's really good I suck at
operating and so for that reason I'm
just going to give you the system and
you can figure out how to operate the
business I was like I still believe you
and then you don't feel like he was
like oh I guess I can just tell the
truth and so the whole impostor Sy
around charging if fundamentally if
someone like you will only have that if
you're misrepresenting something if a
customer wants to pay you for something
and you have the thing and they're
willing to exchange it's voluntary not
holding a gun to them it's exchange
that's how capitalism works you have a
thing they want the thing and there's a
price that they're willing to pay for it
if they're willing to pay for it
phenomenal like that's capitalism we
want and so we try and do it as many
times as we can and so the idea of like
having ethics around price is ridiculous
if they're will and you don't want to
sell out of your wallet either there if
you're broke but somebody the thing that
you provide provides a lot of value to a
specific person then you charge based on
the value not based on what's in your
wallet if you're broke and you're like
this really would help me it's like cool
it'll probably help them even more and
if it just happens to help you that's
how capitalism works both parties say
thank you
so part 2B if you're at full capacity
and you're not making money you often
need to just charge more for the thing
you have and if people say no fine guess
what you get to learn how to sell better
and that's a skill that if you want to
build this big business you're going to
have to learn anyways so you might as
well face that boss now instead of just
forever being in this like I guess I
need to expand this business that
already doesn't work but I don't have
the money to expand because the business
doesn't work right and so this is
impossible place that you spend for
years and
years where's my phone I wrote them down
I should know them all but um sometimes
I forget things so let's see what do we
think problem number four is or number
three is oh that actually leads
perfectly so I remembered it before I
pulled it up for the record
uh the third problem that every business
has to solve is not getting over your
skis not overexpanded okay so problem
two often leads to problem three is that
you're not making up in the core
business so you say great I'll do more
of this but more in that instance is
more of the wrong thing like a little
bit isn't working let's try a lot right
you're scaling you're scaling the
problems not the solution and so right
glad that one hit
um and so and so the idea and this H
this happens most frequently I want to
say most frequently with brick and
mortar because it's such a clear unit
where you're like I have one location
that's doing mediocre but I want to have
a big Fran like I can't tell you the
number of times I talk to local
businesses who have this issue and it's
mostly because we have this ego thing
around growing revenue and so a lot of
you guys are like and I say what's your
goal it's like I want to go from 1
million to 3 million I from 3 million to
10 million I want from 10 million to 30
million whatever it is right like
everybody's got this big number goal and
so what happens is you make the goal the
thing that you focus on but when the
goal is an output you then get weird
about in puts because you try and make
the output occur rather than thinking I
have to fix this model where once I get
the inputs clear I Jam as many high
quality inputs into it and then Revenue
occurs revenue is a consequence not a
goal and so the inputs that we put in
the system so when we make what we're
going to do for Content we talk about
how many pieces of content we're going
to make what the schedule that content
is what's the checklist we're going to
follow that will increase the likelihood
that these video views go to the right
people and get the most of them to see
it if we hit 100 million like who like
not who cares of course we care but what
will it change about what we
do all we know is that it'll just give
us feedback to change our inputs but if
you make me hitting this number and not
attach it to what you have to do then
you start building really stupid things
and so this is the classic internet
marketer who scales too fast for their
course business this is the agency who
just takes on lots of clients because
they want to hit this Revenue goal or
the brick-and mor business owner who
opens up a second location when their
first one isn't even working and so it's
like they want to get to they want to
get to three so fast that they'll never
get to
10 and so we did that little thing
earlier where if you build you know a
building as fast as you possibly can you
can't add more on top of it it just
breaks the foundation's not there and so
often times the fastest way to $100
million business is slower to 10
but faster from 50 to 100 and so if you
can actually have that perspective you
won't care if it takes you three years
to get the single location right because
once it's dialed then when you copy
paste it it
works and so the big thing that's
missing when you're doing the
overexpansion thing I'll tell you what
the core issue is it's
who you sell too many people too fast
before you hire train good enough people
to backfill and then you get too many
people in with not enough talent but you
have bodies and not brains and so now
you have to keep selling more people to
manage your overhead of all these dumb
people that you haven't Heen the time to
train and they're dumb because of
outputs and the reason that they're dumb
is because you didn't train them and the
real dummy is you because either you
weren't patient enough to interview more
people or you weren't patient enough to
train them but both of them are your
fault
so you get get overexpanded because you
have this arbitrary goal that was around
growth and not
Quality quality creates growth growth
creates bloat so if you make growth the
goal bloat is what occurs if you make
quality the goal growth occurs as a
result so make getting better the goal
and then you will get bigger if you make
bigger the goal you'll get bigger and
you'll get
worse and so when I hear the many
problems that come here often times
you're over your skis you over extended
you have too many people and not enough
smarts and so rocking hard place I have
to keep selling these customers so I can
cover this overhead but my reputation is
getting worse and worse and worse
because I can't deliver on the promises
but I have to keep making the promises
so I can pay my
bills and that's where your lifestyle
comes into play again you're like I made
a goof up I need to decrease my
lifestyle I'm going to stop taking money
out of the business and I need to have
some hard conversations and I probably
need to work overtime for a while the
thing is is that the over time isn't
like a week or a month sometimes it's
years and it's tough you know like it's
it's tough you give up weekends over and
over and over and over and over again
it's not like you give up weekends you
just have you don't remember the last
time you took one right and so I say
this out of care but
like
it you have to be like the hardest part
of being in business is that you will
always encounter these Rock and hardplay
scenarios because you don't know
everything and until you've been there
you're like this is all going great
until it's not and then you realize
you're whoopsy and so I think your
willingness to endure the pain of
undoing your poor decision is what will
get you out of the long-term pain faster
but the short-term pain is way worse and
so and this is where the Growing Pains
come in because let's say you do pull it
back you stop selling as many new
customers so that you can focus more on
training the team up interviewing new
candidates maybe even having to pay them
more because they're more qualified
because they come in with some knowledge
that you don't have profit starts to
drip starts to dip so what do you do
well you know that if you keep going on
this path and you do fix delivery you do
fix churn all of a sudden you can't get
your head back out of water because now
you're selling people in they staying
and all of a sudden you're starting to
get referrals again because word of
mouth is picking up and then all of a
sudden your profit goes back from
negative to neutral to up to your
previous Max but it just keeps going
again and then you get excited and you
make another dumb mistake and then you
have to repeat the process again and so
the thing is is like the entrepreneurial
growth pass the pain of it is the big
mess ups you realize you make that you
then get into the Rock and heart
situation and most people can't make a
decision so they just straddle it and
stay in the mediocre middle destroy the
reputation and stay stagnant for years
and so you have to like whatever that
hard sticking place you're at is is you
just have to confront it as fast as
human possible and so it's like I always
would rather have intense short-term
pain rather than very long-term
pain of not living up to what I think I
can do so that's sticking point number
three number
four I will say this until I'm blew in
the
face but the fourth problem that every
business owner has to conquer is
focus and what is so nefarious about
Focus it's so sneaky because we are
rewarded as entrepreneurs for taking a
leap of faith for taking a jump when
there's nothing there and then something
starts to work and so that's such a
rewarding experience you go from
complete control to complete Freedom
well technically you go back to control
again but I won't get into that and in
that moment you're like this was the
best decision of my entire life and the
problem is that you should never do it
again because what happens is you
reinforce such a strong Loop where
you're like man and then when this gets
hard like my job was you then think oh
I'll do the same thing I did last time
I'll switch I'll try something new and
then that'll be exciting and new just
like a your relationship and then all of
a sudden you get out of the honeymoon
phase and you realize oh there's
problems in this business too and then
you're like oh I'll do it worked that
other time it still worked half of the
time and so then you jump again but the
reason that it's so nefarious besides
the fact that it's encoded in your DNA
from being an entrepreneur from quitting
your first thing to do this to begin
with is that every time it looks
different and that's why Focus is so
tough and there's always a very strong
argument for why you should do the new
opportunity and that's why by the way as
a sales pitch new opportunity is a great
way to sell because it's so hard to have
the discipline to be like nope I'm just
going to keep doing the thing that I've
been doing for 10 years and I know the
good and I know the bad but I know them
both and I know where I'm deficient and
I just need to do these things better
for the next six months and if I just do
those things better we will grow by 50%
and here's the fun fact about this is
that once you get to a million a month 5
million a month 10 million a month 100
Grand a month
whatever going from that to 50%
more a lot easier than going from zero
to whatever number you were just at so
if you have your current thing you
forget how much you've learned about
what you're in you're in there for 3
years 5 years however many years you've
been in real estate right a
lot and we forget about it but this
other thing has all of these booby traps
all over it right this lady in the in
the red dress has chlamidia she's got
Daddy Issues she's got an ex-boyfriend
with with a gun who who stalks her right
you don't know yet because she presents
the same CU anybody in a first day can
look good anybody on one sheet it's like
hey my buddy's making a killing on this
right and he's like oh yeah I married
her sister didn't tell you about the
baggage right it's that's part of it and
that's why the focus part is so tough
and I had to Define Focus for myself and
I'll Define two words for you because
it's helpful for me so one is commitment
what is commitment a lot of you guys are
like I'm
committed commitment is the elimination
of
Alternatives very simple and so if you
want to become more committed you
eliminate alternatives
and so uh there's an old story of this
where the uh where the the football
coach asks one of the kids on the
football team uh out to breakfast and so
you know they're sitting there having a
good time talking about his game talking
about his future he says you know I'd
like to play college ball and he's like
I think you could I think you could play
college ball he's like but you might not
too and he's like well what do I have to
do he's like well it depends he like
depends on what he leans in he's like
are you interested are you committed
he's
likew I'm I'm committed he's like I
don't know if you are he says you see
your plate and he's got eggs and he's
got ham on his plate he says the chicken
the chicken's interested he's like the
pig the pig's
committed and the point there is that in
order for that breakfast to occur the
chicken keep having eggs over and over
and over again but that pig only has one
breakfast at
serving and so the same way is that we
have have to eliminate Alternatives it's
what we like the the word decision comes
from Latin diader which means to
literally cut off or to kill off and so
the idea is what are what are you
killing today what really juicy
incredibly sexy opportunity that you
know you could crush you turn down
today because you made a
commitment and I've I've I've been
thinking a lot about the decisions of my
life that have had the biggest return
and the more I thought about this the
more I think that actually I'll read
this I'll read this to you because I
think it might it might come across
better that way so I wrote this down um
earlier
today which
is the best diet is the one you follow
the best person to marry is the one you
stay with the best business is the one
you stick with the thing that makes it
the best isn't the thing itself it's our
commitment to
it and so there 's a lot of different
diets that work if you stick with it
there's a lot of different businesses
that will work for you if you stick with
it but none of the diets will work if
you don't and none of the businesses
will work either and I think it's a very
good framework there's a perfect diet
for you that's perfectly measured and
would get you the absolute fastest
results but if you do not stick with it
it won't happen
ever and so it's not about the actual
intricacies of the diet it's about your
willingness to stick it out and so when
you listen to basos and you listen to to
Steve Jobs and you listen to Sam Alman
who was in charge of YC before he
started open AI they talk about this one
thing and they're like you know the more
I've thought about it it's just
persistence it's just being willing to
stay the course Despite All Odds despite
the many shiny objects that come your
way and just say I get it no so
commitment is the elimination of
Alternatives and I measure focus by the
number and quality of things I say no to
and so if you want to give yourself a r
reward cycle which I like to do because
the hardest of these ones that I
struggle with is focus is that every
time I say no I give myself a mental
point it's like I I'm focused I'm making
an active decision to stay focused
because I know that if I just only stay
focused like it's hard to imagine a guy
or a gal who's an entrepreneur and does
just one business for 50 years and
consistently has the hard conversations
and just says I'm going to get better
I'm going to keep learning I'm not going
to repeat the same mistake
and they do that for 50 years and
doesn't become unbelievably successful
it's hard to imagine a world where that
would exist and so we have this blank
check from the universe that says I
guarantee that you will be successful no
matter what if you do one thing which is
you just say no to everything
else and so when I have these
conversations the woman in the red dress
always presents differently and that's
why she's so sneaky and there's always a
very legitimate reason why you could
make money with it and the reality is
you could but you can't do two things
you can't be CEO of two businesses you
can own multiple businesses but I'm
going to be real with you you don't
you're CEO of both and you're running
everything right no no no I've skilled
myself out of the day today so if
something happens in the business what
happens my phone rings right you're not
out of the day to-day if you buy a share
of Apple you're out of the dayto day all
right you're an owner and so use that as
your litmus test do I own this business
or does business own me if it owns you
then you're a CEO welcome to business
right and so there's this big misnomer
between I'm an owner and I'm a CEO and a
lot of people say I'm a small business
owner but you really don't own the
business for a very long time like until
you get to 1020 million a year very
tough to own a business the business
owns you comma that's okay because what
else you g to do right you're G to work
anyways so you have to be on the path
but I think it's good to have Clarity
around that because the amount of times
it's like I've got this new opportunity
vehicle and people always quote my story
back to me they're like hey but you had
the jibs and then you started doing the
turnaround business yeah I was
26 and before that I had nine businesses
and I made no money and so this was a
big Improvement for me right but the
real question is not did it work but was
there an alternative that would have
also worked which is if I had just stuck
with gyms being super real at this point
in my life I probably have two or 3
hundred locations probably worth the
same amount of money I'm
now and so there's the fallacy of
success which
is if I do this thing it will work and
the fact that it works meant that it was
the right call but you can have multiple
outcomes that lead you to where you want
to
go but when you straddle multiple is
where you guarantee that you'll never
get there and I'm just saying this and
I'm trying to beat this into ground
because one I'm shouting at me
mostly but also because it's probably a
third of the conversations I have on a
regular basis and the crazy thing is
that all the problems I just said have
nothing to do with I need more leads I
need to learn how to sell better I need
to follow my leads faster you know I'm
not retaining customers none of that
these are the things that get you stuck
these are very easy problems to solve
Market more do more reps on the sales
reach out faster these are not
complicated things but it's all this
crap that we stay stuck in because we
stay in these Rock and Har Place
scenarios which are the real core issues
and the last problem
bonus that I see on a regular basis that
walks through these doors is you have a
product and you don't have a
business so you sell One widget one time
to one person there's no backend there's
no upsell there's no recurring there's
no Revenue
retention that's from the strict
definition of a business it makes money
so it is technically a business but it
is not an asset that is valuable and so
that's something that you will
consistently have to put inputs into
rather than it be self- sustaining and
so I've always been in the go you know
in the world and probably you are too
we're like I will solve any problem no
matter how complex once but I don't like
having to solve them the same thing over
and over and over and over again but
when you're in that business you have to
just keep doing the same thing over and
over again and the day that you stop is
the day that it dies
which really just means that it's an
amplified version of you in terms of a
job which again is fine but I would
rather build an asset that I can own
rather than just a slightly fancy or
higher leverage job for myself if I can
afford to do it and so when you're
thinking about this with your business
to be clear it's selling a better or
extra version or recurring version of
whatever your thing is so that people
will buy again now there are businesses
where it is reoccurring rather than
recurring Coca-Cola doesn't have M
subscription but they know that I buy
and I will buy again and so if people
are not buying your product again then
figure out why and if your business is
one that doesn't lend itself to that at
all that's one where I would say look at
the other businesses that are super
billion doll businesses in your space
that what have they solved that you
haven't and then that becomes your path
and if there is no business that is in
your space that sells that one thing
that's very big not all businesses are
worth owning and you might think wait
Alex I thought that I had to stick with
the hard thing and so the fundamental
this is the a different Rock and Hard
Place is one of the qu essential
questions of Entrepreneurship is do I
push or do I
pivot and
so nine times out a 10 you have to push
it just means I have a problem that I
don't know how to solve and if you have
a problem that you can at least Define
the problem then you can try and solve
it if you have an issue that the market
fundamentally like wedding
rings if you can only sell one wedding
ring and you have no desire to create
more wedding rings and you're not a
jeweler then it's probably not the right
business for you now the caveat there is
that there's probably a jeweler who that
is the perfect business for and loves
doing all sorts of wedding rings and
then also gets into the girls rings and
gets into multiple rings and and you
know expounds from that because they
have a specific Avatar they can serve so
there's a version of this business that
could work but businesses don't die
entrepreneurs
fade entrepreneurs lose their Sizzle
they lose their love of the business and
so one of the things that has helped me
stay in love with businesses that I have
for longer periods of time and I've had
to learn these disciplines because
that's what it takes to stick with
something for a very long time and if I
know that sticking with something for a
very long time is what's required to to
build this very big thing that I want to
do then I better learn that skill and so
learning to relove new things in the
business which I like to frame as what
do I not know how to do and so I love
personal development I think that
entrepreneurship is one of the best
paths to making yourself better because
you have such a quantitative measure of
saying did you improve and so simply
saying I don't know how to rather than
this business won't work because is a
much more empowering frame so rather
than say hey
this business won't work because the
market doesn't like my stuff you say I
don't know how to Market my
stuff this business won't work because
no one can sell like I can no I don't
know how to get someone else to sell
like I can that's solvable and so simply
reframing what I believe to be problems
that I cast onto the universe is things
that I cannot change where I plac the
finger of blame you flipped to the thumb
of accountability and say this is a
skill deficiency and because it is mine
I can change it and so thinking about
things from that perspective has really
helped me be able to fall in love with
the game of business because I can
constantly feel and see myself
objectively get better these are skills
I didn't have and now I do have this I
couldn't focus on anything for more than
six months at the very beginning of my
career I'm more add than you I promise I
have no direct reports zero can't manage
people I don't have the skill the
question is what return do I get on
learning everything that ilila has well
she spent the last decade doing it so
that's not going to be a good return on
my time and so but for her to try and
learn all the acquisition and marketing
stuff that I know is going to not be a
good return on her time and so that's
how we divide things up and so I can go
deeper and better on mine and that's how
you start filling out the holes in a
business because
fundamentally every business operates
I'm trying to give a non- bodybuilding
example um but
you need every component of a car to
work right like is the wheel more
important than the engine you need both
if you don't have an engine the car
doesn't move you don't have wheels the
car doesn't
move you don't have a chassis there is
no car right like there's there's these
these core components that have to exist
but once you have those things if you
have better grip on the tires the car
will go faster if you have more
cylinders in there I don't know the car
analogies but you get the idea if you
have faster the car goes faster and so
you can still have components that can
get emphasized but for the business to
work you have to have all the pieces to
go from zero to one but from one to n
it's how many of these things are we
emphasizing and that's where you can
double down on things but being able to
say the problem with this business is
that this is the issue we can't get this
engine needs to be a 16 cylinder and
it's an 8 cylinder okay so I either have
to learn how to build a 16 cylinder
engine or I got to find somebody who
does or I got to buy a 16 cylinder
engine from somebody else right but
those that's how you have to approach it
and so continually relearning that
process has helped me stick with things
because I don't feel like I'm in the
same business anymore I feel like every
six months I'm in a completely different
business because the problems I'm
solving are different and so I'll leave
you with this one last thought which is
that number one I genuinely believe if
you love the business or space that
you're in you can take any business to
100 million
I like I want to challenge somebody to
tell me like a business they can't take
$200 million a year I think you can
absolutely take any business $200
million a
year the second thing is that when you
scale any business no matter the market
at the highest level your day is the
same you manage a handful of very
intelligent people who do their jobs on
your behalf with lots of
Leverage that's the end result of all of
these businesses whatever business
you're in and so if you're in that spot
where you're like I don't like the
business I'm in you're going to get to
the same spot in a different business
that you also won't like you have to
beat the boss so that you can eventually
get to the place where fundamentally
you're going to have a head of marketing
you're going to have have have a head of
sales you're going to have an IT head
you're going to have a head of legal
you're going to have a head of Finance
you're going to have a head of Ops and
customer success every business has it
different words for different Industries
but fundamentally those are the
components and so if you see that as the
natural extreme that's going to occur in
any business the idea of switching
businesses because you want to avoid
what the natural stream will be is
ridiculous because if you succeed all
roads lead there and so that is one of
my antidotes for a weight I should
switch because my day-to-day what I
actually do will not change and neither
will yours and so you have to push
through you have to confront the fact
that it will suck and you have to undo
mistakes and when you undo mistakes it
hurts extra bad but the alternative is
you never fix the mistake you ever grow
which I think is the larger mistake
overall so those are the big five that
people get in the rocking hard place for
business I see these every single
time I I have these conversations over
and over again and everyone thinks that
their situation is unique that they
can't raise prices because their Market
is special right they they can't change
the compensation because everyone will
leave yep and they're going to leave
eventually anyway so you might as well
learn how to fix it now and they think
that in order to hit the goal like they
have to keep selling even though they're
overextended they have no one to help
them you're right keep doing that
forever tell me how that
works right each of these problems feels
in the moment less bad to keep doing it
but what you have to do is confront it
and that's the boss that you have to
beat at that level so thank you guys for
much for the ads hope you guys enjoyed
the uh Workshop appreciate you and then